there's one shot that holds the crown
for the worst visual effects shot of all
time the rock from The Mummy Returns
now whether that's actually the worst
VFX shot of all time there maybe not but
it sure is goofy looking now we had an
overwhelming response from you guys
asking us to fix the shot and you would
finally have a free day in the studio so
we can gather my VFX Bros or sit down or
talk about and see if we can fix the
Scorpion King
this movie is another honest attempt at
recreating the charm that Indiana Jones
had I know we did it mommy was
successful oh here we go
all right guys pretty good so far it's
okay so far but so far it looks good
animations great they're using that
Jurassic Park kind of limited lighting
[Music]
see that doesn't look bad the animation
for the Scorpion itself is excellent
whoever at hand animated this book and
frickin killed it and also the
Lighting's really solid like the
scorpions body itself blends really well
at the scene and like the Q's doll the
flames going off and that effects
lighting I'm sparking like that all
looks really good and they have this
close-up shot of the rocks face and I
think there's a great discovery that
happened right then wherever you
realized the human face is way more
difficult than just having CG stuff in
the scene the expressions don't seem to
kind of like sync up at any one
particular point causing the face they
look a little unnatural yeah like one
half his face smiles the other his face
is frowning right here happy Rock angry
rocking that's the thing and it's like
the lips like a just before the eyes
adjust they think oh if that's what it
seemed like a little bit everything just
feels like it's not quite synced up he's
too dry but I guess you know if you're a
scorpion entombed for thousands of years
like you'd probably be good little
crusty you got mummy dust all over them
let's just pretend that there's been
eternal flames burning for thousands of
years while he's been entombed he'd be
pretty too sweaty I mean if you look at
the faces of the other characters in the
scene you can tell that there's this
level of like specular detail on all of
them it's like maybe it's either like a
sharpness or the specularity on their
skin is shinier but it looks a little
like waxy and plasticky compared to
everyone else in the scene and the thing
is like everyone else in the scene has
the same skin tones they're in the same
lighting conditions so there was like
really really good references for what
his face should look like when he paused
here you can see like the little
inconsistencies in the face when we look
at the rocks face it's just kind of like
it's all like yeah super smooth like a
like an amputee and then also just look
at the lighting mismatch there - look
how hot that light is you know it's not
even reflecting off the face another big
thing I noticed so there's a lot of gate
flare from this fire it shines and
reflects onto the film or onto your
camera sensor and that's what's
happening here we're seeing this yellow
streak coming in off the side now
the Scorpion King has been composited on
top of that
when technically he should be underneath
that Flair is that Flair is something
it's happening at the sensor and so he
is part of the scene that flare would be
on top of him so we could fix that as
well and that make him look like is more
part of the shot Sam what are you gonna
fix in this shot what are you gonna do I
am gonna use some cool tricks to add a
little bit of Rumble into the shots and
maybe give the guy a little more weight
and then I'm going to do a little bit of
like 2d relighting to make them blend
with the scene and probably do a little
pass to bring out some highlights
hopefully that works Peter what do you
got those flames are getting no respect
in the sensor I'm gonna extrapolate them
and add some bloom to the edges you know
have some optical flares really get that
light going some imperfections that sort
of thing like a Gordon Ramsay of optical
flares I like it what do you got that
ancient door it's not ancient enough so
I'm gonna make sure that ash is from all
the lost souls are falling off the door
when he interacts with it no how you
gonna fix the face that's a good
question that is the main offender it's
just the rock smug right there is ps2
cinematic just snarling at ya I got a
plan to fix that so before Jove it is I
definitely mention that we actually have
something pretty big at stake here and
we have this VFX artist react series if
we can't pull this shot off no one's
gonna take us seriously in our videos
anymore that's the end of the series
right we could be digging our own graves
with this episode the effects artists
dig their own CG grace
all right somebody hi gentlemen
you each have your tasks for the day
let's do it one two three scorpion one
two three
[Music]
the original shot is like butter smooth
yet it's this big lumbering creature
bonking stuff so I felt like it could be
use a little bit of camera shake you
know on the face here we see this white
fire down in the corner here and we look
at his skin up in this area people's
skin aren't that matted you know if
you've been underground in the cave for
years with your oily skin and you
haven't washed your face and maybe it's
the desert in your hot it's gonna
reflect white so basically what I did
there is it's very very subtle what I'm
doing is I'm taking the footage and I'm
just extracting everything until it's
just like the near whites of the scene
I'm isolating that I'm just bringing
those tones out a little bit more and
then to make it look a little more
natural bring a little even further
extra detail and I'm actually using
noise as my alpha man just to kind of
simulate like the roughness and pores of
human skin and I think it helps because
constancy kind of has a little bit of
extra shine on it right now compared to
the other characters in the scene this
matches better it would apps on you know
sometimes in the world you see something
that's been done and you think I could
do that better and that's exactly what
today's sponsor Ray Khan has done now
let me tell you a little bit about these
headphones originally ray con reached
out to us and they said hey guys would
you be interested in endorsing our
headphones and I said well you gotta
send me some because I need to try them
out with my ears first before I can say
whether or not I actually like them and
whether or not I wanted to tell you
about them there's a bunch of other
wireless headphones out there and you
might have some yourself or you might
still be saving up to buy a pair well
the wait is over here with Ray Khan
because they offer a fantastic quality
at about half of the price of other
premium wireless earbuds now this is
their base model this is the e 50 these
are the ones that I've been using and
they fit great they don't fall out when
I run they sound clear as day no matter
the type of music that I'm listening to
and again they come at about half the
price of other premium wireless earbuds
so if you guys are interested head on
over to buy rake on Comm slash corridor
crew and you'll get 20% off your
purchase that's pretty good a percent
it's not bad not bad at all so as you
know it's my task to do the face this
might seem like an impossible task it's
like am I going to rebuild the rock and
CG am I going to go and like find a
bunch of pictures and do photogrammetry
and rebuild a face do I have a secret
rock 3d model that's the way too much
work and I only have like a day to do
this so here's like when you guys saw
our Tom Cruise be big I should be able
to do the same technique you take a real
Dwayne Johnson I'm gonna put him on a CG
Scorpion King I don't think anyone's
done that before so the thing with the
deep leg is you need to get a bunch of
source material up the face now the rock
right now it does not look like the rock
from The Mummy Returns
that's 2001 rock but you know what I got
a good idea The Scorpion King movie
exists and that's just the rock as a
scorpion king for the entire movie I
spent like two hours
grabbin through the movie I extracted
every single time it was the rock space
it's just the most authentic Scorpion
King experience and source material you
could ever hope for
with these elements of the rock from the
Scorpion King I should be able to
replicate his look very very accurately
theoretically I think this is gonna work
really well would you guys like to see
the thing this is actually a thing that
I've been thinking about a lot too which
is what if we start to use real faces on
CG characters or you're even better yet
what if we train the deep fake algorithm
to learn a CG face and then put it on a
real person what does that gonna look
like there's some really twisted stuff
you can do I think this is the first
step in discovering that first I'm just
gonna play the original for you guys I'm
so excited
dude there's no way to work like with
all the fire light inside of his head
flashing like that dude all right so
that's original here we go that's weird
it's really tamed all the expressions it
was it was that one expression he was
like ruin it his lips like dude like
this so much of the shot still screams
like early 2000s CGI like that plasticky
skin look but changing that face and
improving that face improved the entire
shot as a whole pretty substantially
once again we're fixing this shot and
not redoing it but I think the little
changes we've made will still make a big
difference
all right guys time to the big reveal
take a hold on before we do the big
reveal this wants to say I feel like I
made the shot perfect let me just show
all you guys some little all of it yeah
I redid the whole shot man dude that's
really good refocus we can just go with
that one we don't I guess we don't have
to show the other one one of the JJ's in
this play isn't the fire in front of
space those pawns idea all right
I want to see the actual final
Alex sounds pretty good Wow I think the
shininess paid off a lot this is the
forehead shine the face is definitely
much better the chest shine your
technique works boom like this looks
great yeah man like that's this is a
huge difference right here me gets close
up to the camera we still struggle with
some of the limitations of the
technology and having to do in a day I'm
not trying to make excuses but
definitely like he's busting through the
door here the camera shake is really
nice and getting some like grounding
that's not overdone the dust on contact
with the door like helps connect them to
the world a little bit more let's not
discount Peters flare over the arm here
without a wall of yeah it's one of the
things that's so natural like in normal
looking that once it's in there you just
don't notice it at all
but when it's not in there it makes it
look like the rock super CG well we have
now I definitely is an improvement well
that was a fun day spent in the studio
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
shot and actually if you think there's
another visual effect shot out there
that we could try fixing I'd love to try
more of these and if you want to see
what those look like please consider
subscribing we got a bunch more monkey
experiments to do but just got the
motion capture suit back and we have
some pretty cool plans with that have
you ever want to do an obstacle course
for the obstacle course exists only in
the computer so in real life you're
doing weird things but you can't see
what you're doing until you're looking
at the computer so maybe you haven't
wanted to do that but you will after you
see us do it yeah
subscribe to corridor crew and enjoy the
rest of your time
[Laughter]